tik-tok has taken the world by storm
people are becoming celebrities left and
right Ryan Trahan is trying to get to a
million followers in a week today I'm
also going to download this app and I'm
gonna get to a million followers in a
week or more or however long it takes
honestly day one bring it on
why am i shirtless because everyone's
[ __ ] sure that's on this app so I'm
just getting ready so I'm trying to get
to a million followers on Instagram for
like a year now and honestly I'm kind of
over it you know like there's more to
life than Instagram followers like tick
tock followers so follow me on tick tock
honestly though I was like super
skeptical of tick tock for a while
people have been telling me to download
it and I always thought it was just like
a weird app where like little kids
danced and stuff I just downloaded it
and I'm addicted it's like the new vine
and I'm actually really excited to try
this whole tick tock thing because the
last time we had something like this was
vine and I was actually living in Russia
when vine was popular and so I totally
missed my chance of like doing these
little short funny videos and now is my
chance man
I'm gonna be a tick-tock er and if
you're sitting there right now like a
cuckoo bird well you know what I have to
say to that you're stupid you're stupid
stupid stupid so stupid I don't care
just wait I'll block you out shake you
out I don't care
all right so it's 12 o'clock right now
I'm gonna go eat lunch and I have to
figure out what my first tick-tock of
the day is gonna be there's something to
do with food I'm trying to go tick-tock
final tick I know okay
Twitter love kids no it's not this is a
future tick tock star in front of you
how do you guys feel about it you're
over 15 I hate all you guys Chris are
you trying to become a tick-tock star
too with this look at this setup right
here this is all this is all for dick
dawg is this a tick-tock right here you
teaching people how to like make burgers
punch it too much weight that X you
might be a six-time right at our burger
making like can you explain how to make
burgers but everything just sounds
inappropriate accidentally I have an
idea tell me think so we have a froyo
what if I try to make a perfect swirl
like in your mouth on my mouth
yeah I'm not proud of these first tic
TOCs I was really struggling to come up
with ideas I promise they get better
also anyone who's watching who works at
BuzzFeed I apologize this was stupid and
I didn't touch the room I promise so I'm
sorry thanks
all right so I filmed a couple videos
outside it took me like 10 minutes to
film them I'm gonna edit them now oh my
god it's the never yell poopy dick
police poopy dick boop beep boop but do
I can't use the music but this is a bit
about how long the receipts at CVS arm
[Music]
one thing I can say is tick-tock is a
full-time job alright alright so I'm
done making tic TOCs for now that is 15
I'm just gonna like chill relax maybe
some more ideas will pop into my head
for tomorrow I do feel like my first day
was like a little weak you know what I
mean like I'm not I'm not like super
proud of the videos I was feeling a
little self-conscious so I asked my
friend a day to come down do you think
I'm gonna be able to get to a million
followers um well you failed it in
Savannah I know but I didn't get
Instagram I think I get pic talk like I
feel like I get it why is this happening
alright so something's going on with my
tick-tock like it's literally like I had
videos that were getting views and
they're growing and I'm gonna update you
at the end of the day but the last two
videos I posted are like zero views
after hours I'm gonna reach out to
tick-tock what's going on with my
tick-tock ah they're trying to stop me
man why is no one seeing these tic TOCs
alright so I emailed tick-tock we'll see
what they say now I wait because I can't
upload but it's ok it's ok it's about
falling down and get back up get back up
keep going
it's not about how all right so I came
to Philly for the weekend hopefully some
good tik toks come out of here my mom's
picking me up
so have you downloaded to talk like I
told you I did have you been studying it
are you gonna be able to help me no I
don't like to look at videos yet they do
bishhh tick-tock
so the day is over it's 12 o'clock I'm
gonna go to bed and what a day I spent
an entire day just making tic TOCs guys
is that is that david dobrik in the new
dora movie what Congrats bro the app is
still glitched for me but hopefully it's
just a glitch and tomorrow morning it
works alright so it is the next day and
I just checked my tick-tock and I have
five thousand two hundred and thirty
five followers which is a pretty good
start Andres even cooler is that some of
my videos actually got some pretty big
views my CBS one has two hundred sixteen
thousand views the poopy dick video has
two hundred and ninety six thousand
views I think like really quick goofy
vine style videos do well on this
platform so I'm just gonna keep doing
like silly
funny sketch like videos because I think
the algorithm really favors that and no
joke I feel like I can do this I'm gonna
get to a million followers on tick-tock
oh I know it's a bookmark like a oh my
god
oh my god it actually went viral
[Music]
you